-Our next guest is a talented
actress you know from
movies such as "Three Billboards
Outside Ebbing, Missouri,"
and "Ready or Not,"
as well as shows like
"Nine Perfect Strangers.
She stars in "The Valet,"
which is streaming now on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-It's my publicist.
She's worried you're going to
say something stupid.
-Me too.
I'm nervous. Very nervous.
I'm sweating. Look.
-Oh, Jesus.
Okay, well, can you talk to him
and tell him to stop sweating?
-Hello. I'm Antonio.
-Just try not to say anything.
They'll mostly
be focused on Olivia.
-No, no, I-I don't want to
say anything.
-But if you have to,
just say something like
you're here to support Olivia
on her big night.
-Here to support Olivia
on her big night. Okay.
-Oh, no.
-Please welcome to the show
Samara Weaving, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-I'm very happy to be here.
-You play a very jaded actress
in this film.
And for the premise -- I feel
like people should know it --
you have a secret relationship
with a billionaire
and you are trying to pass off
that you actually
have a relationship with this
valet, who was in that clip,
who was photographed in the back
with the two of you.
-Yes. We're trying to
pull one over the world
and hide our relationship.
-You play a jaded actress,
but you are not yourself
a jaded actress.
You are still capable of
being star-struck.
-Yeah, not yet.
-Okay. That's good.
-Not yet.
-I hope you get there one day.
-Oh, I can't wait.
-But I do think -- Like, I feel
the same way about --
There's still people I meet that
I get super-excited,
like a fan,
to see them in person.
-Look, it's happening right now.
-Really? For me?
-Oh, yes.
Every single human being that's
anything, I'm very sweaty.
-Oh, okay.
I feel like I was --
First, I was
really excited you said that,
and then you said,
"Every human being
who's anything."
-Oh, I'm so sorry!
[ Laughs ]
-It happens for literally any
human being.
-Yeah.
-If they have a pulse, I'm like,
"I can't believe
I'm meeting you."
-Oh, yeah.
I saw a Man with a Sign from
Instagram yesterday.
-You saw a Man with a Sign?
-I saw a Man with a Sign.
-Congratulations!
-I know.
-Where did that happen?
-One of the streets.
-Oh, I see.
You don't want to give away
any of the hints.
-Yeah, no.
-Did you base -- Since you are
not a jaded actress,
did you base your character
on anyone?
-I like that you're
driving that home.
You know, I based it on sort of
1920s Old Hollywood actresses.
-Alright.
-Yeah.
I read a story
where there was one actress
who refused to work
with babies or children
because they would steal
screen time from her.
-That's very smart.
-Yeah.
-They're also awful to work
with, so, yeah.
-Well...
-Yeah.
You -- Paparazzi is
a big part of this film.
Have you had problems with that
either here or in Australia?
-I mean, not really.
You know, but in England,
when I lived there, they're
a bit -- they're intense.
-I think they're known
for their intensity.
-Sure. And I was having coffee
with my dad one day,
and they took photos of us.
And the headline was like,
"Samara Weaving
seen with older gentleman."
That's a bit uncomfortable,
isn't it?
-That is a bit uncomfortable,
especially if your dad
didn't see the pictures,
and he's like,
"Who's this older gentleman?"
-I think he was
maybe a bit excited.
-Yeah. He got a little --
-He was like,
"I'm in the newspaper."
-Yeah. Your parents are
very supportive.
-Yeah.
-I think that's always nice.
Probably why you're not jaded.
-Perhaps.
-They have helped you
over the years
with things like auditions?
-Yes. Yes, they have.
-Is this true that they --
So, you know, when I say --
For people who don't know,
sometimes, you have to send in
tape of yourself for a role.
and you need somebody to
read the off-camera --
-Yeah, you need a reader,
usually, like,
a friend or another actor.
But, yeah, this one --
this one time --
I auditioned for "50 Shades of
Grey" in Los Angeles.
And I went back to Australia,
and my parents had a house
at the time in this remote
part of Australia
called Broulee.
About five people live there.
And my agent called me and said,
"You've got a callback."
And I was thrilled
and then filled with dread,
because the only readers in
the house was my mum or my dad.
And the scene was like,
"You did what where?"
And so I was like, "Oh, gosh.
Okay, mum, do you mind just,
like -- Just look at the wall.
Don't look at me.
Just read these
very salacious lines,
and I'll try my best.
It's a callback, okay?"
And she just stared at me
and was like,
"What are you doing
with your face?"
-Oh, no.
Your mom saw your
"50 Shades of Grey" face?
-Yeah, she did.
It's very traumatic.
-Have things been
the same since?
-Well, it gets worse.
-Okay.
-Because I fired mum.
I said, "You're out."
-Look, if you can't do the job,
you're gone.
-You're done.
So I was like...
"Dad?"
And -- Ugh.
Look, it wasn't great.
He got really into it.
-Yeah.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong.
He actually did get cast, right?
He's in the film?
-He's in the movie.
He's also known as Dakota.
-He's the dignified
older gentleman in
"50 Shades of Grey."
-Yeah. Oh, gosh.
Look, I didn't get it.
And that's fine.
-Yeah. It's fine.
You have been
in some wonderful horror films.
Are you a fan of horror?
-No.
-Okay.
-No. I like the '80s ones,
the ones where you see
the strings.
-Okay. Oh, I see.
-I don't know what this is.
-Those are strings, yeah.
So you don't like
how good the --
at this point,
the CGI is too good.
It's too believable.
-It's too good.
Jump scares -- forget about it.
-So, your husband
actually filmed you,
and you were kind of enough
to -- This is maybe --
I've watched this like
five times today.
This is a very genuine reaction.
-I look really incredible
in this clip.
-You do look --
Thank you for getting
hair and makeup for this clip.
-I look like a worm.
-So this is -- You're
watching -- Is the film "It"?
-The opening of "It."
Couldn't make it.
And this is just
a genuine reaction to it.
-Yeah, he filmed me,
and I didn't realize.
You'll know why I didn't realize
he was filming me,
because I look fantastic.
-You -- I just want to say,
I thought "It" was wonderful.
I think this is
a little bit better.
The film of you watching "It"
might be better than "It."
Let's take a look real quick.
-Oh.
Oh, no!
-That is -- I dare anybody to
show me something
more real in a
film or television show.
-It got animalistic.
It was guttural.
Limbic system firing off.
-Thank you for sharing it and
thanks for being here.
It's really such
a delight to meet you.
-Thank you!
-You guys,
that's Samara Weaving.
"The Valet"
is streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back.